this is what lockdown looks like in
london
a city which has declared a major
incident so out of control is the spread
of coronavirus
the fear is that not everyone is
following the rules
governments launched an offensive urging
people to act
like you have the virus if it is
essential to go out remember
wash your hands cover your face indoors
and keep your distance from others
while many of these people are out for
their daily permitted exercise
data suggests this lockdown isn't
limiting public mixing
as effectively as the march lockdown and
it's not driving down the spread either
looking at how the park is today i think
people are tired of being isolated
and just you know like just confined in
those four walls
i think a lot of people think it's much
less of an issue than it actually is
if it's not close to you then it doesn't
exist for some people we have to take
some responsibility for ourselves i have
responsibility for my children
they're actually very low risk i'm a
little higher risk
but i'm life is about an element of risk
the most powerful messaging comes not
from tv adverts
but from inside hospitals and people
like phil a children's football coach
i'm struggling to breathe without help
with oxygen
and steroids i'm a 35 year-old man
healthy sporty with no underlying
conditions
um but have it unfortunately got the
better of me
the public seemingly aren't buying into
this set of lockdown rules as they have
done previously
and there could be a number of factors
at play one
is the lack of consistency in the rules
between the nations
another is a lack of clarity about what
those rules actually are
or perhaps there's just been a decline
in that feeling of collective
social responsibility police
are enforcing lockdown rules more
stringently these officers warning
people about
sitting down in the park we really are
damned if we do and damned if we don't
so we're trying to find that middle
ground but there will inevitably be more
enforcement
because unfortunately we're seeing more
people who are willfully
breaking the rules in surrey they're
trying this
a traveling reminder of social
distancing rules
they worry people from london are
driving to beauty spots for exercise
and bringing the virus with them i think
it is a balance it's a sensible balance
i mean i think 20 miles probably is not
okay most people would be able to find
some countryside where they could
they could exercise nearer than that i
think i think you know this is about
people being
continuing to be responsible until mass
vaccination can be achieved
the only way this virus can be subdued
is by controlling human
behaviour and that is far easier said
than done
martha kellner sky news